bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur rt france manifestation
inédite donc à cuba contre le
gouvernement c'est une crise avant tout
sociale selon vous alors vous n'avez
quasiment tout dit dans votre reportage
qui avait précédé cet entretien oui bien
sûr il ya une crise sociale comme
d'ailleurs la pandémie la généraliser
quasiment dans toute l'amérique latine
en outre d'importantes manifestations en
haïti y en que l'on vit d'ailleurs c'est
très amusant de voir joe biden se
féliciter des manifestations remarquable
à cuba alors qu'il ya eu un silence
total de sa part sur les manifestations
que l'on vu qu'ils ont fait 70 morts il
ya pas très longtemps mais effectivement
il ya dans cette crise d'abord une par
une par interne à cuba y compris le
président nigrelli l'as cannes elle la
lia il ya quelques mois la télévision il
a fait l'inter dans lequel il a
mentionné les pénuries du matériel
indiscutable les difficultés rencontrées
par la population il a il a également
condamné à la télévision les les
fardeaux de la bureaucratie du
centralisme de l'inefficacité donc ça
c'est les problèmes internes à cuba mail
par ailleurs ses prises
elle est évidemment démultipliée par les
conséquences de la pandémie
la ville y qui a entraîné une
contraction générale de l'économie et
surtout une réduction cacit au cas où
l'activité tourisme qui représente en
gros à 7 % 12 7% du pib de cuba qui
génère de l'emploi qui a chuté de 11%
arnaud une va donc tu vas être plongé
dans une économie très dur qui entraîne
des pénuries et qui entraîne un malaise
social
cela étant une fois qu'on a dit ça parce
qu'il ya effectivement les fameuses
relations entre cuba et les etats unis
selon vous c'est bien la polémique a été
aussi le catalyseur de cette de cette
crise sociale dimanche la pandémie elle
elle aggrave la situation
mais le problème central de cette
situation c'est le plus économique
financier commercial et en trace depuis
plus de 60 ans alain développement de
cuba faut se rappeler que
le 23 juin dernier l'assemblée générale
des nations unies a pour la 20e fois 892
condamné l'embargo imposé à cuba s'est
uni avec pour seul détracteur les
etats-unis israël et puis les absences
au brésil dans les colonies de l'épaule
l'ensemble de ce qu'on appelle la
communauté internationale condamne ces
pandas et il se trouve que
l'administration de donald trump a entre
2,7 et 2,8 21 adopté tenez vous bien
243 mesures pour renforcir le véritable
siège qui vise à asphyxier 10 et 55 de
ces mesures ont été prises en pleine
pandémie et c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement cubain parle de death fixie
économique halde a raison et là il a
raison dans un depuis le renversement de
le renforcement de l'embargo par par
trump le système bancaire point qu'hier
cubain est de plus en plus de
difficultés à trouver des banques à
l'extérieur des institutions financières
qui acceptent des transactions en
dollars avec lille
vous avez une interdiction de l'arrivée
de carburant dans tout pays qui a causé
qui cause des problèmes dans les
transports publics urbains et ruraux
vous avez les difficultés d'accès aux
médicaments aux appareils indispensables
à la réalisation d'opérations
chirurgicales donc c'est un problème
qu'on connaît depuis depuis très
longtemps en fait à cuba le le poids le
poids extrêmement lourd de des sanctions
américaines contre contre lui est-ce
qu'on peut quand même parler d'une
remise en cause du gouvernement cubain
parce qu'on a quand même entendu à bas
la dictature
parmi les manifestants c'est assez
inédit quand même comme comme slogan
pour les manifestants aux cubains pas
complètement il ya déjà eu une certaine
manière calme et à l'intervention bien
il a eu bien évidement vétérans siens
dax pas une opposition par parfaitement
respectable qui pour des raisons
diverses et opposées au régime
gouvernement au pouvoir
mais là encore ce états unis il faut il
faut il faut rajouter un élément pas ce
que c'est
est une guerre économique politique
appartient aux preneurs
le jet du département d'état que voit
familles dont des pro démocratie
décennale cuba c'est à dire que en fait
l'administration des états unis
financent un certain nombre des groupes
d'opposition à cuba vous avez la
fondation nationale en anglais qui a été
créé par un africain en 1983 qui est
depuis 2007 sont donc évidemment
évidemment des tensions
ça ça crée des opposants qui sont
extrêmement radicaliser et et qui ont
pour objectif ce qu'on connaît très bien
ce qu'on connaît très bien en
géopolitique internationale qui est le
changement de régime merci beaucoup
maurice lemoine pour toutes ces
précisions je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste et spécialiste de l'amérique
latine merci à vous